can you please explain the different
types of biomarker gases we call them
bio signatures or techn signatures could
look for pollution you look for
chlorocarbons right from your you know
hairspray on your alien world okay you
know that would be a slam dunk for life
even though it's not one of the things
we've historically always studied wait
wa so the Chlor fluorocarbons they're
idiots but they're idiots we can see
right intelligent like there exactly
they're getting rid of their ozone layer
which is probably what they're saying
about us when they actually see the
biomarkers from this
phosphate was one of them uh so
phosphine is something people have
talked about possibly being detected
possibly in Venus and whether that's a
sign a life or something else it's
probably something else there but I
think there are lots of detections of
all of these more complicated molecules
right where you start putting things
together that would be there only if you
had life on the surface that could be
caused by life right you know like the
chlorofluorocarbons would only be caused
by life but methane could be common from
something else